[Music]
okay let me say this i love conspiracy
theories okay yes i'm not like i haven't
written books like i'm not all like
what's in my head and the reason she
doesn't write them down because then
they'll know
that's why we all have that friend my
friend
happens to be
rachel cruz
[Music]
what's up this is jon with the dr john
deloney show
so glad you're with us
it's a great great day listen we did it
we did it
number one book in the nation adult
nonfiction we crushed it
number one dude i've never been number
one at anything
i've been number one on being late and
i've been number one on being annoying
like that guy's the most annoying guy in
the room i've been number one never been
number one this is awesome listen
james and kelly and the whole gang
everybody in the club back there thank
y'all congratulations none of this
happens without you guys it's so good
appreciate it very very proud of you it
was fun congrats way to go
high five
and then the bigger accomplishment drum
roll please
[Music]
is
kelly you got this is your ten year
anniversary
yes i'm not with your husband
been a little longer but yes been with
the company 10 years now how did you do
that
i've never worked somewhere 10 years
without stopping
i don't because i love what i do
oh gosh
no one's gonna hear your answer
except for the listeners there's only
like 36 of them hey we did some book
tours there's more than 17 now we've at
least doubled that it's huge
i think the number of people that told
me they're one of the 17 was like 36
we're in
but let's like seriously how did you
make it 10 years
i don't know i mean i've worked a lot of
places and
i know how good i have it here so yeah
you just keep keep taking it and believe
it or not i even like doing this show
yes
yes unlike james who's ugh
every day he just has his head down on
his computer
this is what gaslighting sounds like
that's probably fair that means you've
been listening to the show too much all
right let's go to amanda in buffalo new
york what's up amanda
hi good morning how are you doctor john
fantastic how are you
i'm all right i'm all right is it cold
in buffalo
yes we're very much ready for uh some
nice summer weather
well good i'm waving my weather wand and
i hope you get it awesome thank you
thank you so i have a question today
with dealing with a
mother-in-law
we basically my husband and i we just
don't know how to set boundaries when it
comes to helping her understand her
comfort level with coming out for visits
as well as dealing with other things
that she often kind of throws at us in
conversation over the phone okay tell me
some
so
anytime we call her it's typically we
get the
oh you guys never call me and yet those
calls are always the ones that we sent
out
um it's never it's always a one-way
street um
also she always complains that we don't
come out enough for visits
and then when we say well why don't you
come out you know we have four kids
we're kind of busy we got a lot going on
we'd love for you to come out and visit
she has you know all her children are
grown so it's just her and her husband
and um she just makes excuses and when
she does come out
you know she always picks a fight mainly
with me and then complains to my husband
about it
and um when we go out to her house her
one son my husband's brother half
brother
lives there as well and it's just
there's smoking in the home there's
excessive drinking
and there's constant vulgar um talking
lots of
vulgar not even just swear words just
very vulgar in front of our young
children and we just don't feel
comfortable with it anymore we don't
know how to address it sounds like
working with kelly and james
lots of smoking and drinking and just
vulgarness
um
so
it seems
here in like on this side of the phone
it seems like a really simple
next few steps what's the hang up what
are you hanging on to is your husband
unable to
have hard conversations is it you like
what what are the challenges
yeah he definitely struggles um he
didn't really grow up with her okay so i
don't know if that's kind of a hiccup
but anytime i bring it up like why don't
you just say something it's like no i
don't really want to say anything
and you know when we go out there it's
like it's not our house so it's not our
place to critique or judge and we don't
try to but at the same token we have to
protect our family we're just not quite
sure how to make those boundaries known
or most more so i guess giving my
husband the aid he needs to make those
boundaries okay
so
what your husband needs to make those
boundaries is a backbone
he needs to look at his wife and you
have little ones
yeah we have four the oldest is 13 and
the youngest is three yeah he needs to
look at his four kids and say y'all are
worth
um being safe
and being protected and not having your
minds
melted and not being around dysfunction
and he needs to look at his wife and say
i love you enough to protect not protect
in like a
braveheart kind of way or like a
gladiator but protect like you don't
need to put up with that crap you don't
need to put up with someone calling you
once a month are you calling them just
you're doing your duty to be kind
and the whole conversation is where
you're lacking and where you're failing
or you're not enough
he needs to get in between you and his
mother
and
so far he hasn't so
two things moving forward have you sat
down with him and said i need you to
have this conversation
or is it just this wish
okay
we have and it's just it's
mostly
i don't wanna you know i don't wanna
basically ruffle her feathers not with
those words but
more or less i guess he just doesn't
i guess he needs the
i don't know
exactly but he needs the help so and i
don't know what that means or what that
looks like
um
it may look like you having the
conversation too
okay and
it may be hey here's what um is gonna
happen for the holidays
and
when you start setting up boundaries
expect people to run as hard as they can
like a battering ram into them to see if
they hold
okay um
here's the deal we're not coming over to
your house if there's smoking and
drinking at the house
and here the thing about judgment
i judge my friends all the time i love
them too
and so i think
judgment has got a bad rap um i'll tell
my friends that's the stupidest thing of
why did you do that you're an idiot and
they do the same to me they're i've
given them permission to judge me right
and i have to judge situations all the
time for my kids and say is this a safe
one is this a is this a nursing
environment is this
a wise choice to send you to x y or z so
i'm always judging things so i think
it's fair to look at a group of people
who continue to smoke and drink and be
super vulgar around your young children
and say i'm not putting my kids in that
environment
okay i still love you i'm glad that
you're human beings and i respect you
and great and partridge into pear tree
but i'm not gonna put my kids there
and when they come back with oh cause
you think you're better than us you mean
no
i just don't want my kids around that
and here's the thing
if they want to be around your kids then
they get to choose
to quit smoking or drinking if you're
involving around your kids
it's that simple
and the
switch for your family needs to be this
mom is choosing to not be in
relationship with us
and that hurts and that stinks
right now if your husband has spent some
time estranged from his mom he's trying
to prop up a fantasy
that somehow the the disconnection was
his fault last time and he wants to make
sure it's not his fault this time
and the reality is he's got a crummy mom
a very unplugged unengaged i would say
crummy that's not cool a unplugged
disengaged struggling with her own
set of struggles mother
okay
does that sound fair
yeah absolutely absolutely she left when
he was a young boy so and there's been a
young boy inside of him wondering what
he did wrong for a long time and i got
her back and he's not about to
be the person who puts the gap in that
relationship even if it hurts his kids
and even if it causes separation with
his wife
that makes sense it is hard
and it's the next right move
or just quit calling
that's the other i mean just stop
calling
okay well
we've done that where we've gone some
time without talking and then she calls
him what did i do wrong what did i make
you mad and it's just that you know that
shaming and that guilt yeah like what
and then he could say no
like you know i mean like i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna give that type of
uh my friend dave what's he say that
sometimes parents can be a travel agent
for guilt trips right i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna carry that brick for you
oh and now i suck as your kid or now i'm
a bat like no i'm gonna carry that for
you you can hand it to me i'm not going
to hold it that's yours to carry if you
want to carry that around
um
if she's somebody who can hear then he's
like yeah man phones work both ways
highways do too
and by the way when you're in our house
there is no smoking inside there's no
smoking outside if you don't want it um
you guys may have to put the alcohol
away
even if you have wine and good bourbon
up in the cabinet when your
mother-in-law and her husband are in
town you put the alcohol away because
you're gonna live by example
and if somebody says something in front
of your kid and i've done this with
family members when they're telling a
joke or saying something i've stopped
him and said no stop
not in this house and especially not in
front of my children
and it's been uncomfortable
and it stopped
and then they got a choice to make do i
want to be in relationship with a guy
who doesn't want me saying those type of
jokes around his kids
does that make sense and i know i'm
making it sound very light and it's
taking me a decade to get where i'm at
now so it's not easy
um
but it's really really important and
here's some small potatoes
um my parents have a small house where
they live they live in kind of a patio
home
and so when we go we get a hotel
and it's better for all of us
we all get sleep they all get sleep and
sometimes my kids will spend the night
in their guest room but it's just better
for everybody and then they have their
evenings and then we've got so it works
for our family and they were
it wasn't weird when we said hey this is
how we're going to do this
and they were great about it and so
sometimes it takes that mutual um
maturity on both sides but hey here's
gonna be the best thing for our family
we're not gonna get there until midnight
so we're gonna hotel and we're gonna
stay here and it's got a pool here so we
can burn off some energy and
so it just works for our family you know
i'm saying so we've just set up some
boundaries along the way um and i'm just
grateful that my parents and my in-laws
are are great at having those
conversations but
um at the end of the day
your husband has to say my kids and my
wife are worth more than the fantasy of
me trying to prop up
a mother who abandoned me once and i'm
worried it's gonna abandon me again
and that's hard
no question about heart
i'd love to see you all get together and
plan hey what do we want the holidays to
look like what do we want our lives to
look like and then we're gonna backfill
that with the relationships that we have
and those that we're gonna have to
marginalize and if somebody's not
respecting your
vulgarity wishes your drugs and alcohol
and whatever whatever you whatever world
you all have constructed for yourselves
then it's up to you to put up boundaries
and say that relationship's not gonna be
a part of our life anymore
and that's hard
and i'll say it again and it's really
hard
and there's freedom on the other side of
that conversation though
we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john dolone show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
deloney
all right we are back let's go to dylan
in virginia what's up brother dylan
nothing much what's going on john how's
your day going rocking on dudes it is
stunning beautiful outside here in
nashville today so i'm doing great man
how about you
uh it's a little warm i like the cold
weather a little better but uh ain't
complaining very cool man so what's up
brother how can i help
so i
am enrolled in becoming a full-time
firefighter and the whole process is
to be coming to a close here pretty soon
and i'll be on time i'll be full time
congrats man
yeah so i'm very excited about it but
obviously it's something that's totally
different than anything i've ever done
before yeah and i want to get ahead of
the curb and just knowing that there's
going to be some
hard things some dramatic things that
will be going on i want to be sure i
have tools going into that that can help
me prepare for that so when i do come in
contact with i know how to handle it a
little better so
like even things just so i can keep a
good relationship with my wife
uh make sure that uh our marriage stays
strong and that communication is good
through
uh hard times i don't shut down or
anything like that
that's awesome man so what what what
about the time in the academy has made
you think i'm probably gonna need
some tools
um
it's more so just from hearing
i i've got a couple buddies who are
firefighters and a couple that are emts
and just hearing them talk about how
there's going to be some times where you
might come up on a scene where there's
uh death
or um things of that nature i don't i've
never run into that before so i don't
know how i'm going to react to it gotcha
um so i just i more so just want to kind
of prepare myself with like either some
tips or tools so i i know that i will
handle that properly when the time comes
awesome man well dude no
i wish every single fireman police
officer
every first responder would have your
your mindset going into this thing
um
that is that i mean this just puts you
miles ahead of your compadres that's
incredible and i'm proud of you um and
do you have little ones
uh meet too
wife for trying uh and hopefully in the
future um it's gonna be a little crazy
if it happens right at the time of like
because i haven't started the academy
yet okay couple months away okay but uh
just the government process and things
like that but uh you mean the government
isn't completely smooth and efficient in
virginia that's strange
um okay well so
on behalf of the little ones that are to
come and your marriage good for you man
good for you all right i'm gonna throw a
bunch at you here okay
and i got my notepad ready oh
like a firefighter way to go um and i
also want stop me if you have any
further like dig into just you cut me
off okay because i can talk a lot and
talk too fast
um okay so
the first one here and i i brought some
notes um kelly let me know this call was
coming so i brought some notes here just
to make sure i want to make sure i
honored you and your profession
and your colleagues across the country
who are listening to this in the right
way or somebody who happens to be
married to a firefighter or to a police
officer to a veteran who's coming home
or just about to leave
or to a nurse or to a surgeon or any of
those folks who do this hard stuff for a
living
so the first thing is you're already
there mostly okay
the first one is understand discomfort
and challenge and seeing hard things
is part of this job
a lot of times we enter into
hard seasons and we expect it to be
perfect or maybe not me or it shouldn't
be this way
and a cornerstone of being a fire
firefighter and slash ems
is you are called
when the worst of the worst is happening
right when there's been the multi-car
pileup when the person is passed out in
the street and is or been hit by a
motorcycle or has their house i've sat
in people's front yards and watched
their house burn with them and the
firefighters are all around like that's
that job right
and so
this may be a
maybe a terrible way to live
but i expect people to be dishonest on
occasion
to exaggerate things i expect people to
steal on occasions not everybody but i
expect that to happen sometimes
and my life doesn't end when it happens
i'm disappointed i'm frustrated i get
angry but my life doesn't end and so
hear me say this okay
expect to do cpr on somebody someday
that won't make it
and expect to
do like you'll roll out on a call and
y'all will get there just a few minutes
too late
and expect to respond to burn down homes
and businesses that is the job
perfect endings are not the job showing
up in people's worst mess is the job and
so we're creating an identity here
the identity is not that we're going to
make things perfect
i'm the kind of guy who shows up
in the worst of the worst
and when you frame it that way you give
your body an opportunity to live into
that identity versus i'm in someone who
um tries to solve everybody's problems
or sell everyone's messes that's a
recipe for disaster i'm a guy who shows
up when things are a mess
period full stop okay number two
um when you get calls and you'll get the
call out codes right that say hey
there's this is ems call this is a car
wreck this is with the potential fire
this is a fire with potential victims
this is a multi-unit fire right you'll
get your call outs
go all in
where i see people get tripped up is
when they get to a scene and they're
timid
or they think they can avoid something
i had a partner she was a riot dude
she's one of the funniest awesome
greatest professionals ever but she was
like i don't do dead bodies
and
i used to be like
uh that's kind of what we do
like we do that and she's like i know i
don't do that part
and she was like she's still one of my
closest friends i love her but she um
that was always like part of the it of
course she would eventually do it but
know that don't tiptoe be active when
you show up go all in and begin to prime
yourself to go all in and we often hedge
like uh i'm gonna
there's somebody's passed away in that
room over there i'm gonna kind of walk
by and kind of do perfect just go in and
be a part of the solution to that
challenge okay is that you hear what i'm
saying
yeah all right now here's where things
are gonna get grindy okay
this is gonna go against all popular
wisdom
and this is something that i absolutely
kick myself
on a
somewhat regular basis for not having
done
keep a journal
or a record
that is private
and give people names
i wish i had done this and i hadn't
the conventional wisdom is as a crisis
responder is to
use refer to victims of their homes by
the call numbers by their addresses by
their um tag numbers give people names
and
write them down and if you're a person
of faith
write a quick prayer for that person in
their family if you're not a person of
faith write a quick well-meaning wish to
that person to their family
whenever possible use their name so to
quote vanderkulk your body is keeping a
score of all of these challenging
situations you run up on whether you
want to believe it or not and what
what
secondary traumatic stress ultimately is
what burnout ultimately is is when your
body says i can't keep carrying all of
this it's unprocessed
it's raw brick
and if you sit down and say
tonight off shift
i went to two car wrecks
one had a young child who passed away
one had a mother who broke her leg
one had an older gentleman who was just
shaken up really badly
and i'm gonna give those kids a name i'm
going to write them down in my journal
and just say
young boy
we're going to miss you
we love you
and i did the best that i possibly could
for you
and i want you to lean in that level and
it's going to feel heavy at first
but your body will process the trauma
there okay hear what i'm saying
yes and this will get
cumbersome
the next one number four you gotta have
a gang you gotta have a band of brothers
the body processes trauma and secondary
traumatic stress with and through other
people
and here's the challenge for
firefighters your band has to include
firefighters in it
that's your gang and it has to involve
people who are not firefighters at all
who have nothing to do with that
profession
okay
yeah i'd also recommend getting some
sort of
at least initially some sort of
counselor you can check in with that
will be confidential that's
unless you have feel real safe with your
unit and your captain that is not
affiliated anyway with the firehouse
just to somebody in your community
here's what we're looking for someone
you can be a hundred percent honest with
last night i was super scared
i saw a young child who had been burned
and
i can't sleep
you need to be able to say hey yeah go
ahead um would that
would what would would it be a benefit
to have that person you'd be 100 honest
with your spouse or would that be would
they be reserved for another
uh type of support so my next bullet
point here on my notes is your wife is
not a trash bin
okay
so
i've shown up to scenes
that i will never tell my wife about
okay she doesn't need that in her head i
don't need that in my head and it's
there
i have been talking about scenes before
and just hanging out with some guys that
were like
have goatees and drink whiskey straight
and go hunting like just like dudes who
who
um are very uh
like
stereotypical like yeah bro and i just
said hey one time and i told them about
part of a scene
and dude i melted the room and that's
when i realized oh i'm part of a small
group of people
who does this does that make sense
yeah and so what i did develop with my
wife is the language which is i saw some
really hard stuff last night and it's
haunting me right now
and um i'm gonna need a minute
and then i'm gonna need a minute became
i need to need to go to the gym i need
to go hang out with my friends i need to
go for a run or a walk i developed some
activity-based behaviors on the back end
of those that minute but i didn't come
home and say hey honey guess what i saw
last night
i just didn't do that man it wasn't fair
to her
so it would be kind of
you would i assume that it would be your
house and your spouse
is kind of a safe space and kind of a
happy place if you were to bring that
stuff in you would be almost tainting
the atmosphere a little bit like your
escape from it all well it's less than
it sounds
no think of it this way um think of it
as you've probably heard me say the
bricks in the backpack think about it
like you're going to a scene
and what a firefighter does is it runs
in and helps carry people's bricks
and if you walk home and just toss that
to your wife over breakfast she can't
carry that she doesn't have the training
she doesn't have the the
um the group of people in her life to
carry that stuff you know i mean it's a
it's a lot and she will concoct a
mixture of horror movies she's seen
um sons of anarchy episodes she saw and
then what you just told like so it won't
even be real it'll be a myth and it will
be a mess
and so sometimes some spouses want to
hear that kind of stuff
some don't mind does not mine is not and
the challenge that most find is either
they use their spouse as a trash bin
they come home and just dump it all out
or they say nothing to anybody
and neither of those options is wise
what my home is a safe place for me
here's a good example um this is just a
personal thing that happened the other
day
um
i have a weird thing about traveling
more than 24-hour drive from my kids
it's a strange thing
and
we were planning our 20th anniversary
this summer where are we going to go and
we could go here we could go there we
could go there so we're trying to work
on child care and my wife was she's kind
of making fun of me just because he's
like oh i guess i can't go there because
it's just too far
and finally i said have never told you
this here's why
the number of times i had to call
parents
and say your son or daughter probably is
not going to make the night you need to
go on a plane right now
i made that call too much
and she looked at me and it's like
we've been married for 20 years why are
you just not telling me that and i was
like i don't know
but i always just
kept it to myself hey what if instead of
going to seattle what if we just went to
north carolina
um what if we just vacationed in texas
where we live it's cool let's just stay
here
i should have said my fears out loud and
i didn't
and so for 10 years 15 years my wife has
been thinking a certain thing about me
that was wrong but it's my own fault i
didn't speak it i didn't say it out loud
now i didn't tell her about all of the
weeping and the crying and the moms who
showed up late and i didn't i didn't
bring her into that but i did tell her
hey this is a thing i wrestle with
and i'm gonna have to get over too cause
i wanna go to london and i wanna go to
mexico i wanna do some cool stuff and so
i'm gonna have to get over my hang-ups
too
but that was the truth my body's keeping
tabs to that stuff does that make sense
yeah all right so here is i got two more
for you
number five watch out for shifting bell
curves
100 of your professional day will be
spent
dealing with
other people's
issues
in incidents that never happen to
anybody
we all know somebody who knows somebody
whose kid got in a car wreck and died we
all know somebody who knows somebody
whose house burned down
we know somebody who knows somebody who
right and some of us have have
first-hand knowledge
most of us most of the time will go
through our lives and that will never
happen to us
percent of your day is dealing with
people's houses on fire or in car wrecks
or
in cardiac arrest in a grocery store
and so what happens in real short order
is you begin to see the world through
that professional prism
that every situation is a potential fire
every situation is a potential car wreck
every grocery store someone might drop
dead
and the tendency is to retreat out of
your life
and the
greatest thing you can do
is to be around other people
who do not share your profession
make sure you are fishing make sure you
are going outside and playing catch you
have a softball league make sure you are
working on cars whatever it is that
you're a golfer don't be a golfer dude
don't be a golfer but find things that
ground you with other people and what i
would say is a healthy dose of reality
because you're gonna get the gnarly dose
of reality most of us walk through life
not believing that one little spark can
burn our whole house down
we should probably be shaken out of that
stupor because we act dumb or the way i
drive
like dude you're gonna get yourself
killed right i need to drive better on
the other side
fatal accidents why common are very rare
right and your bell curve will shift
hear what i'm saying
yeah in the academy you'll probably have
some sessions on how not to bring this
home
pay close attention to those sessions
because what you don't want to do is to
become a panic monger for your young
children or for your wife all right
here's the last one
your feelings or your feelings
feel them
period
okay here's what i mean
i had times when i walked in on a scene
and there were guts everywhere it's a
mess
and i wasn't grossed out
and on the way home i thought well
that's weird
i would have thought i would have been
grossed out by what i just saw
because it was insane
and then
one day i walked into a scene
and we were sitting with a mother who
had four or five young children
and her husband had taken his life
in the bedroom of one of the kids
and she went in to wake the kid up
and found that scene and had to get
husband down and out of the room before
the toddler woke up
and i walked into that room to be with
mom when she told her kids that daddy
had died
and there was several social workers in
the room me and my partner in the room i
think there was even we took three of us
that time because there were so many
young kids
and
it was the first time i ever walked out
of a room
uh she started telling the kids and the
oldest kid took off and he started
crying the youngest kid just started
banging stuff
and i looked at my partner and said i
gotta go
and she said you can't go i said i can't
be in this
room. i had a baby girl at a toddler
and my body said get out of this room in
a way that it had never done it before
and it really hasn't since
and so why do i tell you that
your body is going to do things that
other guys bodies aren't going to do now
when you're a fireman you can't leave
you're there right you leave when the
scene's over and um i had we had
multiple people there so i was able to
step out and i waited until the whole
thing was done
blah blah blah but here's what i'm
telling you
some guys in your unit are gonna show up
on a scene they're gonna be like dude
that was crazy that was awesome and
you're gonna vomit all over the place
and that's okay
in some situations you're gonna leave
and you're not scared at all it wasn't
even weird and that's okay too because
you're going to think you're nuts
all that to say is your feelings are
your feelings own them they're yours
write them down
and say
i felt scared last night i felt alive
last night i made jokes at a scene that
was kind of weird and i kind of freaked
myself out
that's part of the gig okay is that fair
yeah don't get into a
feeling comparison game with the people
around you you are you and you're
uniquely made okay
it's how you're going to deal with those
feelings how i'm going to be whole how
i'm going to deal with health and taking
care of myself on the back end cool
yeah
yeah go ahead i'm sorry um that was
actually something that
uh i had thought about is because i can
only think through it mentally of like
what
of what it like all this would be and
when i think about it like it it doesn't
really bother me before of like it
freaks me out or anything like that and
it kind of was an odd feeling like
should i feel like i'm
that's right freaking out like it should
sympathize bother me yeah like even like
the thought of it uh
but uh that last one uh definitely made
sense to me on that it will get you at
different times in different seasons
the only other time i ever walked out
was when
another tragedy happened to a really
young child and i had a really young
child now i can walk into those
situations with no problem i mean
they're still awful and brutal that but
i can do i can take care of business in
those situations now
if i walked up on a scene with a 12 year
old little boy i'd really struggle with
that
yeah right because my body is highly
tuned to the safety of a young 12 year
old little boy so be gracious with
yourself in that process and know when
i've got to step out
and that will that should i mean that's
why you train so that you don't ever
step out and you train and you train and
you train and you train so that when you
but your body goes whoa
you become uh it goes into automated
mode right i got it here's i gotta
follow my safety protocol i gotta get in
that house here's how we're gonna put
the fire out here's we're gonna get the
people out you train so much
so that it becomes automated so that
you're not subject to your feelings it's
more when you're driving home
or those quiet nights when you're at
home your wife's asleep and you're in
the shower
and that hot water is running down your
neck and you say to yourself inside your
own mind i can't believe i saw what i
just saw or i can't believe i just
pulled somebody out of that car or i
can't believe fill in the blank
feel those feel those feel those and
then make sure you've got people to talk
about it with i am so grateful for your
service my brother we need more people
like you out there thank you thank you
for loving your community we'll be right
back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe cause you got an expert and a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumer access dot org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane sweet
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right hey what's up we're back and
it's time i don't know why i'm yelling
this is kind of a low-key chill show but
we're back and it is time for
everybody's favorite segment
facts are your friends
now listen
i stumbled on this article back in 2019
and it came back up again recently and
it's by the great peter atiyah peter at
tia md.com we'll link to it in the show
notes and um he sends out a weekly
newsletter
after sign up for his newsletter before
mine but get on his he's just wise um
but he wrote about conspiracy theories
and he wrote an article on conspiracy
theory theories
and if you've been in america the last i
don't know a couple of years there's
been a wide range of conspiracy theories
everywhere so
here's a couple of things he notes
um as why he thinks there's so many
conspiracy theories that have emerged
number one
truth is hard to accept
the idea that a sad and lonely sick man
could climb up in the library window
and shoot a sitting president with all
of the might of the us government around
and alter geopolitics that if that our
our
country is that fragile
or that 19 guys just gotten a couple of
airplanes and crashed him and that's all
it took
to rattle this country to its core
he writes it's better to have a
compelling and elaborate story we tend
to believe that extraordinary events
deserve extraordinary stories we're not
okay with things being that simple
the second thing is there's a history of
genuine conspiracies right um they've
been real like watergate et cetera and
here's what he has an evolutionary
purpose he says we're hardwired for
survival purposes
a splash in the water or movement in the
brush could be a rock in the wind but
better to assume a saber-toothed cat and
a venomous snake is far more likely to
be nothing but on the off chance we're
wrong we need vigilance to stay alive
and there's been some conspiracy
theories a few the third one we're
significant junkies we just want to make
sense out of a confusing world and we're
willing to go along with just those
stories if it helps our brains attach
meaning to them
now
i am somebody who is a big fan of
i don't know data
uh rational thinking logic things like
that it's just like a fun thing for me
we all have that one friend though
that would prefer
to listen to the man with 17 youtube
followers out of the trunk of his car
with a mobile phone microphone going
talking into like a fisher-price radio
set
guess what everybody i figured it out
listen to this we all have that friend
my friend
happens to be
rachel cruz check this out
are you not believing any conspiracy
theories i understand not all of them
not most of them but you don't believe
in any conspiracy there
you just think the government's just
batting a thousand and telling us the
whole truth
that's a strong stance to take
and so
we're back and so in studio i've got my
good friend rachel cruz and we're going
to do this
john it's the greatest cinematic gosh
okay so you guys don't account for
actual humans being greedy and evil in
the midst of all
i could feel it on you oh peter schmeter
i don't know who this man is i don't
know who this man i'm just kidding he's
smartest
i know all right so let's rattle through
some of these okay okay and i'm not okay
let me say this i love conspiracy
theories okay yes i'm not like i haven't
written books like i'm not all like
what's in my head i will translate to
you and i will tell you but i think but
if it comes out of your head but if you
get if you get like you can't like pop
quiz me on like very very specifics of
each one because i'm like i'm not okay
these are all let's go bro
yeah and the reason she doesn't write
them down because then they'll know
that's
all right
number one okay
jfk
oh yeah total inside job total inside
job for sure
have you have you been to the have you
been to the textbook
and if you stood in that window you're a
gun guy john like you you appreciate it
i've never stood in the window you did
well that's part of the tour you go and
you go and buy the window where he shot
you have to be
a phenomenal
sniper to be able to do that three shots
in seven seconds
and a gun that probably is can't look
you can't it just like mechanically
would be very difficult for that to
happen
and to actually aim at a target like
that
i mean i it looks nearly impossible that
and then
you're so happy right now cia the mob
yes for sure lyndon b johnson lyndon b
johnson we're on to you they're coming
to you lyndon i don't know grassy knoll
so i do believe there are multiple
shooters i do think
lee harvey wallswald obviously had
okay but i just think stuff is happening
i just think there was stuff happening
vietnam i mean there was a lot the cia
wanted to go
and assassinate fidel castro okay that's
actually documented okay okay there are
actual documents on that it's clear
there's probably like four different
reasons
why people would want him dead okay
versus some crazy guys like i'm the best
shooter in history and i have a magical
gun that can reload even though that
doesn't exist in the 60s and shoot three
times no the grassy knoll there was a
nut yes other yes other things were
happening moon landing oh we're just
like we're having we're going down oh
wow a moon landing uh i'm going to judge
me
if it if
it didn't happen i wouldn't be shocked
oh why yeah
uh height of the cold war the soviet
union when you look at all of the facts
going against it's like we had to beat
it uh 30 billion dollars was put into
nasa that year 30 billion to do
so if they didn't land on the moon there
would be like this uprising like this
idea of like nasa what do you do like or
they splunk money into the secret alien
operations questioning question
questioning and you look and they had
the tech they did have the film
technology to pull it off yes and what
1963 right no no that was that was that
was jfk i remember the exact date yeah
yeah
69 thank you what about the pictures
like do you think they've there's actual
probes on mars right now
uh no i'm not talking about current okay
you think we think we've we're there now
yeah yeah yeah but that actually
specific yeah it was yeah yeah and then
you look at the pictures though and it
is odd there's no stars like there are a
couple things i'm like they just missed
details
so that's my thought like with that one
i think okay they got a group of
hollywood producers in there to do this
like we guys we had to nail this we have
to trick earth we have to trick the
planet
and of the people in the room they were
like
son of a forgot the stars like really
there's a guy or it's like i just hate
the politics of the day no we have to do
a flag we had to beat the soviet union i
mean there were things and and kennedy
i mean he went on a whole thing right
about
yeah all of it and i just think that
america
he rallied us around something we could
do together
buzz all he he's like punch people i
think
like in real life because
yeah oh yeah
so i don't want to be punched hey listen
listen it could have happened buzz is a
huge listener of our show actually we
did not land on the moon in 1969 i'd be
like i mean i'm just not shocked all
right denver airport oh yeah attempt
airport okay now we're starting to get
real crazy
so you and i have talked just hanging
out like hey john you know there's like
a thing under the denver yeah denver
airport okay what's underneath the
denver airport for our listeners who'd
have no idea okay well the denver
airport so denver had a full functioning
airport very close to the city and it
was fine sure maybe a little small but
it was fine so when you fly to denver
you know you drive like 45 minutes to
get to downtown denver i mean it is out
there right okay
um and if you haven't been to denver
there's these um they're small but
they're around the city
they're called the rocky mountains which
make making big things hard
um that has nothing to do continuously
oh no that is not like no no no no no no
no no no we're not talking geography
here we are we are
focused on facts dang there are so yeah
so no the denver airport one this one is
kind of i get it it sounds silly but
again i'm like i mean who knows okay so
what is it so it's the idea that the new
world order which there's actually a
plaque outside of the denver statue and
literally at the bottom of the statue in
the circle it says dedicated to the new
world order like it really
literally says that so i'm like i don't
understand why people are like oh i know
so the new world order it's not like the
illuminati sort of but it's the idea the
idea that there are a group of people
across the world powerful people that
control everything right like we think
our elections
no it's all it's all controlled by by
this group of people okay so
this is this is the theory i'm not
saying i believe it 100
this is the theory though and so in
order to
control the world and we can bring in
biblical revelation to it like
stuff okay that a mass genocide has to
happen eventually to allow the world
order to control the population because
they can't control every person right
now on the planet clearly there's too
many absolutely uh the antichrist i
don't know like you can you can start to
like weave in some biblical stuff here
but so the idea is that there has to be
a master in the side so you go around
the denver airport today okay
and the paintings have you seen the
paintings on the wall are the creepiest
bizarre some artists and they they blame
them they're like it's art i'm like no
it's not there are literal paintings
google it of a man and a huge man on a
gas mask and coffins below him with with
children of different nations like
different like at the american flag with
different yes there's that photo there i
mean the most weird bizarre dark
paintings are all over the denver
airport so it's hints of painting
of the massachusetts because here's the
conclusion at the bottom of the denver
airport there were all these tunnels
when the construction was happening
there's footage aerial footage of these
massive tunnels underneath the airport
so the theory is is that is where
the new world order is gonna go
stay in these bunkers
when the mass genocide happens so that
they can't survive
literally on this show
i take calls all over people all over
the world
um explain to me what's going on in
their life
and
one time i think on the show maybe twice
i have said the words i don't really
know what to say next
and this is number three i don't have
so we were at family dinner no this was
like this was this one's been around for
like 10 years yeah and we're at ramsey
family dinner and i'm telling my family
this because i'm like this is insane
y'all the denver airport is sketchy like
when you you know and i'm telling them
what i just told you
and dad dave was like that is the
stupidest thing i think i've ever heard
and i was like oh you're innocent
dave ramsey might be part of the new
world order i was like save me a bunker
save me listen one of the one of the
most important things about new world
orders
is they they wink at the world through
their art and statues
and i didn't have any i had no idea i
would have thought why
is it why is that why is the airport
though dedicated to the new world order
would it like
why would they why would they put that
there i'm just curious i thought the new
world order was like a wwe group like a
worldwide wrestling group
right aren't they wrestlers are they
wrestlers why would they dedicate an
airport okay sorry
flat earth
uh i've researched it i don't believe it
i love that you you like i gotta spend
this there's a few documentaries i
watched so i was like what if what if
but i do think the world could have been
out serving the poor and you're like
nope i have another use for that
valuable hour of my life
i got to find out if this earth thing is
real um do you believe in any john do
you think anything like this is true
hold on do you think anything in history
has happened
that is not the truth of what was being
told oh absolutely yes okay so it opens
your mind to the idea that there are
people that do things and they tell the
public one thing and we're all like okay
sure yes that's what's happening yes
when actually
other stuff was really happening i
absolutely do okay and i like them for
fun
yes but i really identify with what he
said about
um
the idea
that
one guy could climb up in there and take
out the president
and alter
world history yes
i don't want to live in that world
and so it feels better it feels better
to say no no there was a huge plot that
everybody knew was in on it and they all
knew what was happening and then they've
pacified the rest of us because we
couldn't handle it
i have been in boardrooms when we've had
hard conversations and nobody lied
walking out but everyone said this
conversation stays here it has to
because
what's going on out there
they can't handle a friend of mine was
uh she was a
an attorney for a finance attorney and
when they were trying to make the fed
minutes public record
and she was like
god help us
they have to be able to have
conversations in there that the general
public cannot stomach we don't need that
made
and i i believe that there are certain
conversations that shouldn't be
everywhere totally right yes yes so yes
i like the idea that okay the cia all
got together like we have to do this
it happened now let's move on
i like that version of the world better
than
no that guy could just go like the whole
thing that we are dancing on is that
flimsy right can you alter that totally
absolutely absolutely um so i like that
but i yes and but for me i'm like it's a
hard balance of
withholding information yes for
security you know and i get that like i
can be rational i understand but also
when you're just lied to when you're
just lied to though there's a part of me
that the justice in that i hate and i do
think there are things that have
happened in our history correct then i'm
like it's just if it's why and and lied
to for the benefit of other people that
if there are powerful people greedy
people and they want what they want
right and in order to get that it's like
well we'll just do this this and this so
i can get more money or more power and
that's where i think some of this can
stem from
last one yes don't go where are you
gonna get your thumbs down because
there's some i don't i don't i won't
okay thumbs up or thumbs down okay
microchips oh yeah oh yeah no those will
those are hat those are actually
literally happening as we speak so for
payment yeah people yeah yeah the bbc
just reported
you can get a microchip now it's
different than pulling it out of your
pocket and waving it over
then just waving it over
uh because it's part of it's it's
you can't you can i can throw that over
there when it's implanted in you john it
is part of you like they literally
when's the last time you've left it over
like that
left my phone
like what do you mean
what do you mean just walked away from
it for
24 hours
uh
2011. 24 hours how yeah how many hours
are we talking
see
ah stop mark and the beast
uh so that's my friend listen are some
conspiracy theory theories real yes but
ah
of course they are but listen
most of the time they're not
most of the time there's a group of
people trying to the best they can i
think with the data that they have
and most of the time i have to look in
the mirror and go
do i really really think that they are
implanting chips in
something and i'm just going to put it
in a soda i'm going to drink it and all
of a sudden like they got me is that
really how it's going to happen oh yeah
i don't know
probably not but the thing is do you
believe that there's evil in the world
though of course so i'm like if these if
evil people
have enough power and enough sway
then it shouldn't be shocking when evil
stuff starts happening right and then
they hide it from us all you know where
they hide it in the denver airport
ladies and gentlemen if you get one
thing out of the segment at all listen
they didn't land on the moon
contrary to what lloyd christmas says in
dumb and dumber and two
never fly to denver we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
all right we are back hey
one quick um
like uh just a note at the end of that
last segment uh i want to read uh what
what dr t writes as he wraps it up and i
i just full feel 100 on this he writes
it's one thing to be skeptical of the
effectiveness of a drug or a moon
landing
but it's another thing to make a blanket
statement right without doing some
serious homework yes skepticism is the
cinque non of science but it's
intellectually dishonest and lazy to
reject evidence that doesn't agree with
your world view without considering that
you may
be fooling yourself
and others right this one's talking
about that vaccines cause autism which
it's been clearly
established that the guy who published
that stuff was completely made it up all
of his findings have been invalidated
and somehow that still hangs around as
though it's a thing right
and so all that to say is when you're
faced with data or evidence of your
particular pet conspiracy theory maybe
maybe go huh maybe i was wrong
and i'm like rachel she's a good friend
i love good conspiracy theory that makes
me happy let's wrap up today's show
oh man we have never had a song by this
group what a great group the group is
new order if you don't know new order
they're so rad they're old school the
song is called truth and it goes like
this
oh it's a strange day in such a lonely
way i saw some children dance i watched
my life in a trance and the people
around me seemed so glad to be here will
my time pass so slowly on the day that i
fear and the noise that surrounds me
pulls so loud in my head from the
promise that healed us to the lies that
i said oh it's a strange day it's such a
such a lonely way
some people look down on me i know they
like what they see such a strange
day
and it's always strange days right here
on the dr john dolone's show see you
later
coming up on the next episode are y'all
still married
we're still married but legally only
they'll share a home we share a home
but it's he knows only because we were
building a home
after we started building a home he
broke my fingers
i would have left him
right then and there
my son was gonna be married the next day
i didn't know what to do
how did he break your fingers
he grabbed him he got angry grabbed him
and crunched him what a scumbag dude